hey it's evan carmichael and like elon
musk says if you're trying to figure out
what others love but you don't love it
it's really hard to make that great and
that's why i make these videos to help
you love what you do and make money
doing it
so today here's my take on elon musk's
top 10 rules for success enjoy
all my life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a process i have us all just uh
implement rigorously is uh the sort of
five-step process uh first make your
requirements less done your requirements
are definitely done
uh does not matter who gave them to you
it's particularly dangerous if a smart
person gave you the requirements because
you might not question them enough then
uh try very hard to delete the part or
process um this is actually very
important if you're not uh occasionally
adding things back in you're not just
leading enough right the bias tends to
be very strongly towards
let's add this part of process step in
case we need it but you can you can
basically make in case arguments for so
many things and for a rocket that is
trying to achieve um
try to be the first fully reusable
rocket there's never been a fully useful
rocket people don't understand like this
is like the holy grail of rocketry okay
and
so you really need you have to run at
tight margins because if you don't run
tight margins uh you're going to get
nothing to orbit right
so
uh so you gotta delete the partner
process step super important anyway so
step one uh make your requirements less
done step two delete the part or process
step if you're not adding if you're not
leading a power processed step at least
ten percent of the time basically if
you're not adding things back in 10
times you're clearly not deleting enough
right
and and then
only the third step is simplify or
optimize the third step yeah the first
step
um the reason is the third step is
because it's very common
possibly the most common error of a
smart engineer is to optimize the thing
that should not exist
right okay
um and and say well how do we get why
would people do that well everyone's
been trained in in uh high school and
college to that you got to answer the
questions convergent logic yeah so you
can tell the professor your question is
done but you'll get a bad grade you have
to answer the question yeah
so everyone's basically without knowing
it they got like mental straight jacket
on uh that is uh
they'll work on optimizing the thing
that should simply not exist finally you
get to step four which is accelerate
cycle time
you're moving too slowly go faster
but don't go faster until you have
worked on the other three things first
um but if you take if you're doing
it you know
you're great don't dig it faster stop
digging your grave right all right
so
uh but it's you can always make things
go faster
and then the final step is automate
um
and uh now i have personally uh made the
mistake of going backwards on all five
steps
multiple times rule number two imagine
an outcome you have to
um imagine an outcome in order to head
in that direction um
and science fiction explores a lot of
different ideas so
um it can be
you know helpful as a source of
inspiration um and any you know
like
books
tv shows movies and they're all
uh i think sources of inspiration um
most of the movies and tv shows that
space are totally wrong uh but
uh
but they still have interesting ideas
like the star trek communicator um
was uh an inspiration for the cell phone
yeah with the flip right right yeah
exactly
um i'm gonna in fact the weird thing is
like the
like the phones we have in our pocket
fastly exceed what was on star trek rule
number three be fired up about the
future
i think that's very exciting and
inspiring and there needs to be things
that are exciting and inspiring and
uh make you
look forward to waking up in the morning
like it's like gay future is exciting
this is underappreciated
you know like tunnels
sorry it's like
and
you know but there's got to be things
that
make you excited about life um
but it can't just be problem solving you
know one one sort of miserable problem
after another it's got to be like i'm
fired up about the future and here's why
you know
and space is one of those things that
that does that for people all around the
world
um
you know when
um
when
apollo 11 you know when they landed on
the moon i mean it was that was
something for all of humanity it really
was you know people would you know if
there's like one tv for 50 miles around
people would walk
you know they'd walk 50 miles just to go
find that one tv to watch it happen
um
so you know sometimes people think what
about what about the poor nations of the
world like you know what inspire
inspires them too
and um
you know we need things like that rule
number four love your work i think like
if if like trying to work on something
and like my experience is like it's
really hard to and like
if you're trying to figure out what
others love but you don't love it it's
really hard to make that great
so when you work on something
if you fall in love with it that's
that's a good sign um
and then don't worry about if others do
if if you do others will
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five cross pollinate
industries an important thing in uh
innovation or trying to create new
things is is to try really hard to to do
that
which may sound incredibly obvious but
that's what i find is is most often what
people don't do they actually didn't try
super hard to
come up with something new
and and it is helpful to have
cross-pollination of industries
i mean it's been quite difficult to run
spacex and tesla but
there has been
good ideas
you know since i got both in my mind
space
this this good idea is going back and
forth the
um for example on the car with respect
to the car the model s is the only
all-aluminum
body and chassis car made in north
america and very few cars are are all
aluminum in the aerospace industry it's
that that's the default um
so it seemed like like
obviously the right move in order to
minimize the the non-battery pack mass
of the car
so in order to offset
you know fairly heavy battery pack we
had to make the rest of the car
light but but still achieve
a five-star safety rating
i don't think it would have been
possible to do that if we use steel
which is the traditional method
and and what's helped spacex has been
that the car industry is
really good at making
complicated objects
at a low cost i mean it's actually quite
incredible that like one can buy
a decent car for twenty thousand dollars
i mean all the stuff that's in that car
is
i mean it's nutty how much stuff is in a
car
um
so
uh
that at spacex i hired a bunch of people
from the order industry to
run manufacturing which has worked out
reasonably well rule number six have
people take responsibility whatever
requirement or constraint you have it
must come with a name not a department
because you can't ask their apartment
you have to ask a person yeah and that
person who's putting forward the
requirement or constraint must agree
that they must take responsibility for
that requirement otherwise you can have
a requirement that basically an intern
two years ago randomly came up with off
the cuff uh and they're not even at the
company anymore right uh and and and but
it came from the let's say
aero loads department they're like uh
actually
there's no one in the airplane's
department actually it currently agrees
with that this is now this is by the way
happened several times so again it could
be literally we're going to pick on the
arrow support but it's like yeah it's
every department rule number seven solve
technical issues there's a lot of uh
technical problems to solve um
so i guess we sort of you know start
studying kind of
engineering and physics and biosciences
and that kind of thing would be the
um way to go
um
yeah
um
a lot gonna be a lot of problems to
solve to to make a city work on mars
um
you know we were thinking of just as a
well sort of a semi joke putting a
uh job description on our website for uh
urban planner and brackets mars
but um
you know there's going to be a
tremendous amount of problems solved
there'll be
there's a lot of building building and
problem solving so those are like the
right you know skills to work on if if
someone's interested in
going beyond earth or you know space in
general rule number eight embrace
failure what's the actual biggest
failure that you that you've gone
through to get to where you are we blew
up three rockets in the beginning
[Music]
so
that was
that that was bad
[Music]
we actually i only had enough money
originally i only i basically took all
the money i made from paypal put it into
spacex to creating spacex tesla and
solarcity and uh
i
initially figured i'd i just i'd keep
half of it and then i spent the other
half on these crazy adventures that
would probably fail
and then
unfortunately they needed all the money
so
so again i had to give them all the
money and then i didn't have a house or
i had to borrow money for rent that was
that was pretty difficult that was back
in 2008.
um
and then we managed to scrape enough
spare parts together to do a fourth
launch at spacex um and that worked and
if it had not worked spacex would have
died and
probably would have lacked the
credibility to raise the remaining money
for tesla
and we wouldn't be here today or maybe
like
not this ending rule number nine remove
in-process testing another mistake that
tends to happen in production is too
much in-process testing
uh so
in the when you're first setting up a
production line
you don't know where the most like where
things are are breaking you don't know
where things are breaking so you'll test
uh
like work in process at various steps
and because you want to isolate where's
where we where's the mistake occurring
so a very common mistake
issue with production
alliance is to have
um
is to not remove the end process testing
uh after you've
diagnosed where the problems are so
basically if you have like um a very
high acceptance if like if things are
getting to end of line testing and or
passing uh then you don't need to do
in-process testing
so uh
but what has to happen is they'll be in
it like an initial like development
engineering team that will be like
basically debugging the production line
but then they will forget to take out
the un-processed testing
uh so then
what happens is the in-process tested
tester
will often choke the cycle time
took the line for action time uh it'll
be like the limiter uh it'll also have
some number of false positives with
false negatives but i mean like false
positive like then you're like rejecting
good parts right um
so um
really in volume production if you have
if things are working well
uh you're really just taking a risk will
this part be re will this
subsystem be rejected at
uh
during the during the production process
or at the end um and so you just really
want to move things pretty much almost
always to just test at the end line
that's it
maybe there's like one or two in process
steps
that are hard to test at the end of line
but that but basically remove almost
everything and rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is create great products if a startup
company did not create an electric
vehicle and show that it's possible to
have an electric car that looks good
goes fast has long range
and that if you created such a thing
that people would buy it then
it would be a very long time before the
large incumbents did so um and so that
was the i felt was important that we
create tesla for that reason now i've
got a special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you i think being in silicon valley is
pretty important because
what's really critical with electric
cars is
uh
electrical engineering software and
electronics
uh and
silicon valley has the best
concentration of talent in those areas
in the world 2008 in particular was was
was awful because um we had the third
launch failure in a row of
of our falcon 1 vehicle at spacex
and
we
the tesla financing round that we were
raising fell apart
um because the economy was going to
tailspin
um and it's pretty hard to raise money
for a startup car company uh you know
late 2008 when jim and chrysler are busy
going bankrupt
um that that was that was tough and then
solar city had to deal with uh morgan
stanley and morgan stanley had to renege
on the deal because they themselves
running out of money
um so it looked like all three companies
were gonna die
and i was also going through divorce so
that was definitely a low point
so it's 2008 you're going through a
divorce which like some to borrow your
word douchebag vloggers are writing
about to make even worse right yes
that's true um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on massively in the press right
yeah you're you know it looks like all
three companies yeah are gonna file i
mean
why do you keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like i've already sunk
everything i have in these companies
and i got to pick one
but you didn't i mean you kept doing all
three why um yeah that was a that was a
very tough call
um
at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the tough you know one of the
toughest goals i've had to make
because i could either
um
reserve capital for one company or the
other i mean before solo city didn't
need a ton of capital so they were okay
but between spacex and and
and tesla
um
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids
and
what do you do do you spend all your
money to to maximize probably the
success of one or do you
try to keep both light unfortunately at
work it's very important to to seek out
to actively seek out
um and listen very carefully to negative
feedback
and this is something that people tend
to avoid because it's it's painful yeah
um
but
but i think this is a very common
mistake is to to not actively seek out
and listen to
uh negative feedback what do you do that
do you go into forums do you go into
twitter like what are your areas where
you go to look for feedback on let's say
the tesla
well it's like everyone i talk to is um
in fact when um when friends get a
product i say look
don't tell me what you like tell me what
you don't like right um and and because
otherwise your friend is not going to
tell you what he doesn't like right this
is going to say oh i love this and that
and and then and leave out the this is
the stuff i don't like list because too
much of your friend want you know it
doesn't want to offend you so um
so you really need to
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback um
and you should you know that if somebody
is your is your friend or at least not
your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback
then
they may be wrong but it's coming from a
good place
and sometimes even your enemies give you
good negative feedback when i started
the first interact companies up to
with my brother and another person um a
great curry the
uh it wasn't really with the thought of
being wealthy
you know got anything against being
wealthy but
um
we'll get back to that later
but it's just it was just from the
standpoint of wanting to be part of the
internet and uh
i i figured if we could make enough
money to just get by would be that would
be okay
um and when we started off uh we we
literally only had like one computer and
so it would be our web server during the
day and i'd code at night
and we we just got a
a
a small office um
in palo alto back when rent was not
insane
and
i think it cost us like 450 a month it
was cheaper than an apartment so we
actually just slept in the office and
then
and then showered at the ymca at page
mill el camino so we'd walk over there
and and shower and uh
and that was um
actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um and uh
so i don't know how many people probably
know many people know this but uh
we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on the zip2 business plan
and actually i thought
she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most people we met did not
actually read our business plan
in fact a lot of people a lot of venture
capitalists we met at the time didn't
even know what the internet was or
they've never used they'd never use that
they're sure that things
still do
yeah
right
yeah i'm sorry like you know sort of
well-known people on sand hill i was
like wow okay
um
but at the time nobody made any any
money on the internet so i guess that's
um
you know it then it wasn't really clear
evidence that that there was was a
business i should say that you know when
i was a kid i didn't really have any
grand designs i mean the reason i
started programming computers is because
i like computer games
and i play lots of computer games and
i learned that if i wrote software and
sold it then i could get more money and
buy better computers so it wasn't really
you know with some grand vision or
anything
when i was growing up i'd read lots of
books
and uh
they were very often set in the united
states and it seemed like a lot of new
technology was being developed in the
united states so i i thought okay i
really want to work on new technology so
i want to get to silicon valley
you know which
when i was growing up silicon valley
seemed like some sort of mythical place
uh you know like mount olympus or
something i think one thing that's
important is
uh if you have a choice of a lower
valuation uh with someone you really
like or a higher evaluation with someone
you have a question mark about take the
lower evaluation
it's it's better to have a higher
quality
uh
venture capitalist who you think is it
would be great to work with than to um
you know get a higher evaluation with
someone
where there's
even a question mark really you know i
think that's that's important it's sort
of like getting married the secret to
your success to be the ceo of two
companies at the same time
no
i think it's uh just look at the
correlation yeah struggling companies
everything's in the craft can in
december 2008 so let's take on a new ceo
gig yeah and same for steve coming back
to alpha no it definitely was not my
intention to be co2 companies um
the uh
i mean after i mean i i there are
certain things that i kind of wanted to
i thought were important to happen and i
thought it was important that
um that there was
that that electric vehicle happened that
there was a success in the electric
vehicle arena
because the
the incumbent companies were convinced
that it was not possible to create a an
electric car that looked good had rain a
good range performance and so forth um
and that even if you did make such a car
it would not sell
because people had this love of gasoline
um and
uh so we had to show that
it was possible to create
a compelling electric car long range
good looking you know all those things
that was a tesla roadster and if you
created if if you made such a thing
people would buy it i certainly was uh
quite um
i was very very bookish i was reading
all the time so i was either reading
uh working on my computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing
um i understand hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy that wonderful boot by
douglas adams that was a that was a key
book for you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination um yeah so
uh i guess when i was
in uh around 12 or 13 i had a company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it
starts seeming quite meaningless and
then
um
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house which you should not read at
age 14
is bad
it's really negative
um
so so uh but then then i read the
hitchhiker's guide the galaxy was like
quite positive i think and
um
and it sort of highlighted the the
an important point which is that a lot
of times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
um and so
uh
the if to agree that we can um better uh
understand the universe then we better
know what questions to ask and
um then whatever the question is that
most approx approximates what's the
meaning of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately get closer to
understanding
and so i thought well to agree that we
can
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and
give knowledge
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing well we've got a lot of work
to do
because we've got
a lot of service centers
and charge stations to construct
so mostly it's like we're trying to
build our service and charge
infrastructure as fast as possible
and
i know this like some of the customers
who have ordered a car they're not in
the major cities so
they're a little unhappy with us because
we are delaying delivery of their car
and
in fact i'm going to apologize to some
of them personally
to exp and explain the reason we are
delaying deliveries because it's we
really want them to have a good
experience but if they're too far from a
service center and and the charging is
not sorted out then they will not have a
good experience um so
we're
going to delay their cars just for a few
months to make sure that they have a
good experience i think it's also
important to reason from first
principles rather than by analogy so the
normal way that we conduct our lives is
we we
we reason by analogy um it's we're doing
this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what um other people are
doing me too type ideas
yeah it's like
yeah slight iterations yeah on on a
theme um
and and uh
and it's
because it's it's kind of mentally
easier to reason by analogy rather than
from first principles but my first
principles is kind of a physics way of
looking at the world
and what that really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what do we sure as true
or sure as possible is true
and then reason up from there
that takes a lot more mental energy um
give me an example of that like what's
one thing that you've done that on that
you feels worked for you sure so
um somebody could say um in fact people
do uh that battery packs are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the pack some of us
noticed that the stereo goes to 11 right
on the other tesla this is a spinal type
reference for those who know that this
one goes to 11 and he just just won more
it's louder than loud that's right
exactly that's right
but no one seems to have noticed the
product lineup so you got the model s
you got the model x oh yeah you've just
trademarked the model e
yeah no one's made it yeah
i know exactly well there's no i guess
there's not a lot of humor and trademark
uh the trademark law you know
um
because yeah obviously we just
trademarked sexy um so uh and and then
we're having this this discussion with
the
like ford um because they um
the ford's council uh
uh
they also didn't get it like because
they're
sort of slightly opposing us using model
e
um and then they saw that we registered
model y and they say oh you're planning
to use model y instead of model e like
no it's just a joke
[Laughter]
we don't do that what does it spell when
trying different things you you got to
have some acceptance of failure as
you're alluding to earlier failure must
be an option if failure is not an option
it's going to result in extremely
conservative choices and
you may not may get something even worse
than lack of innovation things may go
backwards
um
so um if
what you really want
is uh
risk risk
to you you want reward and punishment to
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if
uh if what you're seeking is innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and
only
there should be
minor consequences for lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
should that should be minor um with
significant rewards for trying and
succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding um and big
and
major negative consequences for not
trying or maybe i just blank out the
word doubt
um
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too so i thought we you know
had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who
who doubted us i was like well i think
you're probably right you know um i mean
the number of times uh that i was told
like
uh because i was taking the money from
from paypal and enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but
um and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um
and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people tell me this joke like how do you
make a small fortune in the rocket
industry you start with a large one is
the punchline
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
so um anyway um and it was it almost
came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the national cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later all right
towards the end of 2008
those are the two key things that that
saved spacex otherwise we would have we
would have you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those those doubters were
their probability assessment was correct
but fortunately uh
vader smiled upon us and brought us to
this day
yeah
human space flight was was always the
goal the the fundamental goal spacex as
you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced and along those lines if you
were to go back in time and talk to your
20 year old self would you do anything
differently
go back in time
to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd
if i could i think it would make my far
fewer mistakes obviously if i could go
like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
wouldn't we all be a very long list i'm
like
here let me
write it down or something you know
um
i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um
i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i have a lot count
honestly
um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i like
like that's a
simple sort of mantra
management by rhyming i mean it worked
for homer okay
um
the management programming is
the thing i'm saying like if the if the
schedule's long the design is wrong
we've over complicated the design many
times
um
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
um
with the acid test being
how long will it take to
for this to fly
and if it's going to take a long time
don't do it do something else i think we
we need to push for radical
breakthroughs um and if you don't push
for radical breakthroughs you're not
going to get radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks
um
and and yeah
common sense that
the if you take a big risk in order to
have a big reward there must be a big
risk it's most of the time
you cannot find a
big reward for small risk that's those
are rare
um so you're going to have some
proportionality with the risk and reward
simplify your product as much as
possible
you know and then like if i think of
some of the ways which how does a smart
engineer make dumb mistakes
including you know
is optimize something that shouldn't
exist
don't optimize something that shouldn't
exist
if people are trained to do this in
college you can't say no to the
professor you know the professor's going
to give you the
exam and you've got to answer all the
questions
or they will get angry
so
they give you a bad grade so then you
you always
optimize the you always answer the
question
a lot of times you should say this is
the wrong question
right in fact the question is definitely
wrong to some degree just how wrong
and i think just generally taking the
approach that
your design is
some degree wrong probably a lot more
than you think
your goal is to make it less wrong over
time but one of the fun things for me is
watching the the cargo go into the crew
vessel you know all of a sudden we had
dragon one now we have crew dragon and
it's substantially different but
familiar so tell us like what's been
some of the hardest parts to transition
from cargo into crew because the crew is
a little more important than
than cargo yes i mean cargo can be
replaced crew cannot um and so the
the level of scrutiny the level of
attention is
i mean i don't know order of magnitude
greater i mean it was it was it was
already high for cargo i mean
and and uh but it's it's just a whole
nother level for for a crew um so
you know after and aft i told the spacex
team that you know the
uh
this mission reliability is not really
the top priority it is the only priority
right now um so we're just doing
continuous uh engineering reviews uh
from now
non-stop uh 24 hours a day until launch
just going over everything again and
again and again and i was out at the pad
just recently just walking down the
rocket
um we've got a team that's just crawling
over the rocket in the horizontal then
we're going to rotate it vertical then
we're going to crawl all over in the
vertical
and
we're just looking for
any
any possible action that can improve the
probability of success no matter how
small whether that comes from an intern
or me or anyone what sort of things do
you look for in people or in processes
that make the workforce better
sure well i think
the massive thing that can be done is to
make sure your incentive structure is
such that
innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished they've got to be
a character stick
so
if somebody is
innovating
and
doing
making good progress
then they should be promoted sooner and
if somebody is completely failing to
innovate
not every role requires innovation but
if they're in a role where innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited
and let me tell you you'll get promote
you could you'll you'll you'll get
innovation real fast your actual total
mass of a steel
uh
of a reusable steel spacecraft is less
than that of the most advanced carbon
fiber
vehicle
you could possibly imagine yeah wow but
this
happened by accident by the way this may
sound like some great insight but it
actually happened because we were moving
too slowly on composite
and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt so
just do this with steel so yeah i mean
the design has to be focused on problem
solving otherwise you're going to spend
too much time trying to figure you don't
start with a
yeah yeah i'm like
sort of taken to management management
by rhyming if the schedule is
schedule is long your design is wrong
zip2 started off um as
basically
uh like so we're trying to figure out
how to how to make enough money to exist
as a company and
the
so so since there wasn't really any
advertising money being made
uh we thought we could
help existing companies
get online bring their stuff online so
we developed software that helped bring
um
love in newspapers and media companies
online because they alone just didn't
they also didn't know what the internet
was or the customers didn't yeah
and even the ones that were aware of the
internet didn't have a software team so
they could they weren't very good at
developing functionality
um and uh so we had as um investors and
customers uh the new york times company
knight redder hearst
and and so we were able to
get them to pay us to develop software
for them to bring them online so online
publishing stuff we did maps and
directions and yellow pages and white
pages and
various other things you don't need
college learning learn stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
um
there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
and get it done
you know that's
that's like
the main value of college and then also
you know if you you if you probably want
to hang around with a bunch of people
your own age for a while instead of
going right into the workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning the real
way i think you you actually achieve
intellectual property protection is by
innovating fast enough if your rate of
innovation is high then
you don't need to worry about protecting
vip
because
other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast um
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
um
and i do i do say this to my teams like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
want to say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
um 100 improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different
so
it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that matters and is the rate of
innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
and a weird thing happens when companies
get big is that most companies
or organizations the bigger they get
they tend to
get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
um
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh
is not
there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation the incentive
structure must be aligned with that
that's fundamental you need to work if
depending on how well you want to do and
particularly if you're starting a
company you need to work super hard
so what what does super hard mean
well when my brother and i were starting
our first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented a small office and we slept on
the couch
and we we showered at the the ymca
and uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so the
the website was up during the day
and i was coding at night
seven days a week all the time
and i i
sort of briefly had a girlfriend in that
period and in order to
be with me she has to sleep in the
office
so
i
work hard like
it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if if you particularly if you're
starting a company
um
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working 50
hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as
the other company i came to conclusion
that um my initial premise was was wrong
uh that in fact
the um
there's there's a great deal of oil uh
you know that there's there's not such a
shortage
um but people don't think there's a way
um and and that if people thought there
was there was a way or do something that
wouldn't
break the federal budget um
then then people would support it um
which in retrospect i think is actually
kind of obvious because
um
the the united states is a distillation
of the human spirit of exploration
people came here from other places um i
mean it's
you know there's no nation there's no i
mean there's no nation that that's more
a nation of explorers than united united
states but but people need to believe
that it's possible and it's that it's
not you know it's they're not going to
give up like healthcare or something
important
you know it's just it's got to be
that that that's important so
so i thought okay well
then it's not a question of well it's
it's a question of showing that there's
a way in the beginning nobody wanted a
tesla i can tell you that
uh
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to the sports car
uh people were like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline
car works fine
um like no electric car is better i
should try it
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive
nobody knew who we were and they
remember this company
and like yeah we're named after nikola
tesla you know that guy nope
um
um
so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said there was
no one telling us that they wanted an
electric car so it was not it was not
out of like
you know there's like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
an electric car
i heard that zero times um
somebody like it's like man we're gonna
make an electric car and show that these
things can be good um and then people
want them
um
you know it's like i guess like henry
ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say a faster horse
so if you did like a big survey and say
well hey public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food and
uh
you know be stronger and
live longer and that kind of thing um
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um
because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's that sounds crazy
but when you actually make an automobile
and give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
[Laughter]
yeah
so carry more more weight than a horse
and go further and that kind of thing so
yeah the
it's like when when it's a radically new
product people don't know that they want
it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey
i think this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey will you ever buy a tv
now i was like 96 percent of respondents
said no
someone some crazy number
like basically everyone's like would you
buy a tv and maybe they put a price in
there or something
but
it was famously
almost everyone said they would not buy
tv but they didn't know what they're
talking about
so the big game-changing stuff at the
beginning is a company push kind of a
thing most of the time but then changes
to the product over time can be a lot
more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah changes the product over time can
be
incremental changes
um
then the customers can certainly tell
you it's good to get customer feedback
to say how can we improve the product um
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over time customer
feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing
is is great i think failure is bad um i
don't think it's good
but if if if something's important
enough then you you do it even though
the risk of failure is high
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome is is that it's not going to
work
and they should reconcile themselves to
that
past strong possibility
and they should only do it if they feel
that they're
they're they're really compelled to do
it
you know
because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's the very beginning it's kind of fun
and then it's really hellish for
a number of years you talked about
chewing glass
yeah there's
there's a friend of mine who's
uh successful entrepreneur
and
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully
he said yeah your starting company is
like eating glass and staring into the
abyss um
and
and you agree with that
generally true
um
yeah
and and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not going to be successful we
have a lot of good good people at spacex
that
um
a lot of really talented people
uh
in fact i wonder like sometimes
how we can make use of their talents
in the best way because you know i think
we're often not using their talents in
the best way
um
yeah but
you know to the point of the question i
was just asked i want to make sure tesla
recruiting does not have anything that
says requires
university because that's absurd
uh
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability
i don't consider going to college
evidence of exceptional ability
in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know
you look at like you know
gates is a pretty smart guy he dropped
out
john was pretty smart he dropped out you
know larry ellison a smart guy he
dropped out
like
obviously not needed i think of the
these things is just
there's a certain amount of time and
within that time you want the
the best net outcome so
for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do
there's
going to be
uh and some of which will fail some
which will succeed
and you want the
the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
um
so
um
i'm going to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch until that you get a real easy one
they didn't give you three shots and the
third one they say okay they
get off the
go back to the
put somebody else up there um
so these your three strikes on on the
baseball
um
not you know not on the bad anymore so
so what you're what you're really
looking for is like what's the batting
average
you know how how you doing on
uh
on score
and and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure um
but you you want your net output
um
that useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic don't just follow the trend
so um
you may have heard me say
that it's good to think in terms of
the physics approach of first principles
which is
rather than reasoning by analogy you
boil things down to
the most fundamental truths you can
imagine and you reason up from there
and this is a good way to figure out if
if something really makes sense or if
it's just
what everybody else is doing
it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything it
takes a lot of effort
but if you're trying to do something new
it's the best way to think
and that framework was developed by by
physicists to figure out
counterintuitive things
um like quantum mechanics so
it's really a powerful powerful method i
believe in the scientific method and one
should be one should have a healthy
skepticism of things in general and
you know as if first things from a
scientific standpoint you always look at
things probabilistically not
definitively and so i think a lot of
times if somebody's a skeptic in the
science community what they're really
saying is that they're not sure that
it's 100 certain that that this is the
case but that's that's that's not the
point the point is um
that is is it's looking from the other
side see
what do you think the percentage chance
is of of this being catastrophic for
some meaningful percentage of the
earth's population
um is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment i mean think
about a company a company is is a group
of people that are organized to create a
product or service
that's a sort of company is so in order
to
create such a thing you have to convince
others to join you in your effort
and
and and so they have to be convinced
that that that it's a sensible thing
that uh it's like that there's at least
some some good some reasonable chance of
success uh and if if there is success
that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
um
and uh
you know so i think that's
getting people to to
believe in what you're doing uh and in
in you is is
um
so in the beginning
there will be there will be a few people
who
who who believe in you or in what you're
doing
and
but then over time as you make progress
the the evidence will build and
and more people will believe in what
you're doing so
um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um
to create it to have a demonstration or
you know if it's a product to have like
a a good mock-up or even if it's
software to
have good demo wear
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
get a rate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible if you're
going to try something innovative then
then you're in unexplored territories so
that odds that something will go wrong
are pretty high uh if
you know it's only if you try to do
something that is already well
understood that um there's
a little little chance of failure um but
then it will not be uh interesting or
innovative um
so
you know for sure uncharted territory
will result in
failures
necessarily otherwise you know trying
hard enough did you surround yourself
with mentors how did you who did you
look to for advice
i read a lot of books and talked to lots
of people
i didn't have any any one person who was
a mentor uh but i i always look for
feedback from from people around me and
feedback from uh in historical context
to you know which is books basically you
want to have a
competitive
situation where it's truly competitive
uh where companies aren't gaming the
system
um and
and then where the rules are set
correctly um and then you need to be on
the alert for regulatory capture where
the the referees are in fact captured by
the players um which is you know and
the players should not control the
referees you're running you're ceo of
two companies you're chairman of solar
city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep
uh
yeah sometimes not enough sleep is
really great uh because
because if i find if i don't get enough
sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way
and and and also
um like i try to sort of figure out
what's the right amount of sleep
because like i found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it that would
get less done because
my
mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours on average per night um that's not
too bad yeah right and any other tips on
average though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously i mean do
you do you find i mean i know you're up
here monday tuesday is it all tesla when
you're up in silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a
sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during
interstitial periods like you're in a
car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere you can do email practically
when you're awake
um
and uh
and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
um
and then uh
and then just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working actually working
so the way i generally do it is i'll be
working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to the bay area
spent tuesday
and wednesday at the barrier
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spent thursday and
friday
at spacex
in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or
spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex and generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable to figure out if success is at
least one of the possibilities right
exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes um but but ideally you
want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah
um and i wasn't quite sure if that was
the case um i mean i think success on an
academic level would have been quite
likely because you can publish some
useless paper and uh
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect i'm
sorry i mean that's what we have how
many phd papers are actually used by
someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not it's not
good yeah
uh
and
so
so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some
leaves to the tree of knowledge yeah
okay um and then that leaf is nope it's
not possible
right
they go seven years a month
so that what so that was one path and i
was prepared to do that but then the
internet was the error came along and i
was like okay the internet i'm pretty
sure success is one of the possible
outcomes and it seems like i could
either do
do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help build it in some fashion you
know put a you know
like i just couldn't stand the idea of
watching it happen yeah yeah so that
that's uh so i decided to put things on
hold uh and start an internet company
and that was kind of a
we we worked on internet
like publishing software maps and
directions yellow pages kind of things
first of all when we interview people we
we do ask for some evidence of
exceptional ability which in most cases
includes innovation
this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering to be
innovative
and ideally everyone is at least some to
some degree innovative
uh so at the
interview point
we
select for it for people who who want to
create new technology
and then the incentive structure
is set up that such that
uh
innovation is rewarded
um making mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um and but but failure to try to
innovate
at all comes with a big penalty
you'll be fired okay
yeah all right the carrot and stick yes
the steak if you don't even try um or or
somebody doesn't even try to invade or
their innovation
aspirations are are very are
not not very good
then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company i don't have a mentor per se
although i try to
i try to get feedback from as many
people as possible
um
and um
so i have like friends and i ask them to
you know what they think of this that
that and the other thing and
um
you know
as much you know larry's a good relay
page is a good friend of mine value his
advice a lot
um
and um i have many other good friends
and uh so so i think it's good to
solicit feedback
and particularly negative feedback
actually because you know obviously
people aren't don't love the idea of
giving you negative feedback um unless
unless it's like some
you know on on blogs they they do that i
had a lot of friends might try to talk
me out of starting a rocket company
because they thought it was crazy and a
friend of mine made me watch a video of
rockets blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that had
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded and they try to talk me out of
it and um
but the thing is that
the premise for talking out of it was
well we think you're going to lose the
money that you invest i was like well um
that was my expectation anyway so i
don't really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rank ordered best way to invest
money right on that basis
um
you know chose space right i felt like
that's
you know i thought wow you weren't
looking at like money money market bonds
triple a bonds rocket companies you
weren't like do real estate yeah
you know uh
invest in shoemaking anything um
and whoa space is the highest roi yeah
that is not what i there's no no it
wasn't famous
um i just thought that it was important
that humanity expand beyond earth and
we weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to kind of spur
spur that on you know you want to take a
moment to appreciate things in life and
the sensations
um
food's incredible
and like there's just so many good
things that you can experience
some of them cost nothing really
you know
have a walk in nature or
just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great you know and uh
we should take a moment to appreciate
these these uh
little things the big things
um
the things that move your heart i think
that's probably the meaning of life as
close definitions as i can think you
want to have like a
good competitive forcing function so
that uh you have to make the product
better uh or or you'll lose like if you
don't make the product better and and
and improve the product for the end
consumer then then that company should
have relatively less prosperity compared
to company that makes better products um
now now the car industry you know is
actually pretty competitive uh so that's
good
um
and uh and and so then the the the good
thing about a competitive
industry is that if you make a product
that's better it's gonna do better in
the marketplace how much of your success
do you attribute to having really
audacious goals or
versus
um just not being focused on
the short term
you know money coming in or
investors unfortunately i i when one
does have to be focused on
the short term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will will die
so that the
i think that a lot of times people think
like creating companies
going to be fun i would say it's not
it's really not that fun i mean there
are periods of fun and there are periods
of where it's just awful um
and particularly if you're a ceo of the
company
um
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right so you
only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong
and and there are things that are going
wrong that other people can't can't take
care of so you're like the worst you
have a filter for the crappiest problem
in the company
the most pernicious and painful problem
um
so i wouldn't say it's it's i think you
have to feel quite compelled to do it
um and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who who says like starting companies
like
staring into your bus and eating glass
and there's some truth to that
um
the staring into the best part is that
you're going to be constantly facing the
the
um
extermination of the company uh because
most startups fail
it's like 90 percent ugly 99 of startups
fail
so
so you that that's the staring into this
part you're constantly saying okay
if if if i don't get this right the
company will die
um
it should be quite rightful quite
stressful
and and then um
the eating glass part is
you've got you've got to do
you've got to do the problems you're
going to you're going to work on the
problems that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on
and
so that
that's you end up working on problems
that that you'd really wish you weren't
working on and so that's the eating
glass part
um
and that goes on for a long time running
a public company
is
does have its drawbacks
so you're not in a hurry no
okay um i mean in the case of
tesla and spacex
uh we had to raise capital um and and we
had kind of a complex equity structure
that needed to be resolved by
by going public
and
[Music]
and so so i thought we kind of needed to
do that in those two cases
we don't have to do that in spacex i
think
i think there's a good chance it will at
some point in the future
but but spacex's objectives are super
long term and and the market is is not
so i'm a bit worried that if we did go
public certainly if we're in public too
soon that it that market pressure would
would force us to do
uh
short-term things and abandon kind of
long-term projects like going to mars
right very much very long-term when i
was in in high school i thought i'd most
likely be doing physics at a particle
accelerator so that's what as
um
physics and computers i mean i got
distinctions in two areas in physics and
computer science and those were
those yeah so my two best subjects and
i
and then i thought okay well that i want
to figure out what's the nature of the
universe and um
so
you know go try to
working with people banging particles
together see what happens
um
and um
and then it sort of things went along
and the the super conducting super
collider got cancelled in the us and
that actually was like whoa you know
what if i i'm working at a collider
it's been all these years and then the
government just cancels it wow and then
that would i was like hoping i can do
that
so
um
so it's like
well we roll back a little
um
like i i tried to figure out what when i
was killed i had like this existential
crisis and i was about 12 years old or
something and
and i was like well what does the world
mean wait
what's it all about are you living some
meaningless existence
and then um
i met i made the mistake of reading
nietzsche and job now and
yes and i'm like
wow
don't do that it's not it's not to not
seem a little older i think
now actually lately these days i sort of
rear it so like
you know it's actually he's not that bad
wait he's he's got issues he's got
issues no question about it but
but you know it's anyway um
so
uh but there are the hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy douglas adams uh
which is like quite really quite a good
book in philosophy i think and i was
like okay
we don't really know what the answer is
obviously uh so but the universe the
universe is the answer and really what
are the questions we should be asking to
better understand the nature of the
universe and so then to the degree that
we expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
then we'll better be able to answer the
ask the questions
and understand the
why we're here or what what it's all
about and so we should sort of take the
set of actions that are most likely to
result in us understanding
what questions to ask about the nature
of the universe i always thought we
would fail so
this is all it's all upside down you
know i thought maybe we had a 10 chance
of reaching orbit starting out so
then
uh
if people thought
when we started spacex they said oh
you're going to fail
so i agree i think we probably will fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway
yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this this
i said i'd lose like
you know lose all the money from paypal
i was like well you're probably right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches the falcon one didn't
work and the fourth one we scraped
together some parts and
then that one worked and if that one
hadn't worked you would have been that
would have been it for us so
um
i really believe in the future of space
and and i think it's important that we
become a space frank civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction
novels and movies not to be science
fiction forever we want them to be real
one day if you think you're like what is
education like you're basically
downloading data and algorithms into
your brain
and
it's it's actually
amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore um
so you're making it way way better um
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of things that i would say you've
probably heard a hundred times um
and and a fact are if if not doing like
the more you can gamify
the uh the process of learning the
better like
for my kids i do not have to encourage
them to play video games yeah okay i
have to like pry them from their hands
like like crack yes yes like drop that
crack needle yeah yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack isn't addictive
um
so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow learning like a
game that then it's better um
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion um
you've got
uh you know someone's standing up there
kind of lecturing at people
um and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it and that lack of
enthusiasm you know is conveyed to the
students that they're not very excited
about it they don't know why they're
there like why are we learning this
stuff we don't even know why um in fact
i think a lot of things people learn
probably there's no point in learning
them um
because they never use them in the
future because who's going to launch a
rocket into space i mean that's just
like yeah exactly that never happens
um well you have to say like people i
think don't stand back and say well why
are we teaching people these things and
we should tell them probably why we're
teaching these things because a lot of
kids are just in school kind of puzzled
as to why they're there
yeah
and i think if you can explain the why
of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand they understand purpose yeah
um
so i think that's pretty important and
think about the various problems that
we're facing or what would most likely
change the future um
the when they were in college there were
five things that i thought would be
um i mean i thought these were actually
these these i would not regard this as a
profound insight but rather an obvious
one
uh
the
the internet would fundamentally change
humanity because it's it's like
humanity will become more of a super
organism because the internet is like
the nervous system um now suddenly any
part of the human
human organisms
anywhere where you have access to all
the information amazing instantly zero
link hey well like imagine if you didn't
have a nervous system
you wouldn't know what's going on your
fingers wouldn't know what's going on
your toes knows what's going on you'd
have to do it by diffusion
um
and yeah and the way information used to
work was really by diffusion one human
would have to call another human or or
or write them yes like if it was
a letter
you would have to write like you'd have
to have that letter to another human
that would be carried through a bunch of
things find another person would give it
to you
extremely slow diffusion
um and if you wanted access to books if
you were not did not have a library
you're not you don't have it that's it
so um
now you have access to all the books
instantly
um
and
you if you can be in a remote like
you know mountain top jungle location or
something and have access to
all of humanity's information if you've
got a link to the internet
this was a fundamental profound change
let me just tell the story that you can
correct the story
i mean yeah let's see if the story that
you tell is actually how does that how
that compares to the reality because the
reality is pretty messed up so
hopefully the reality is better so you
wreck the car you get out of the car
you're doubling over with laughter
and the person with you said
why are you laughing that you just
wrecked this car and you said no you
don't know the funny part it wasn't
insured
[Laughter]
well
the punch line's correct
[Laughter]
um
yeah so i was actually i was driving up
sand hill road
with with peter thiel the co-founders of
paypal we're actually driving to see
mike moritz
um this is in in uh 2000.
and so we're driving up to san jose i
didn't really know how to drive the
mclaren and peter says so
so what can this do
[Laughter]
and then like
i'm probably number one on the list of
famous last words i said watch this
[Laughter]
so i so i floored it i floored it and
did a lane change um on on santiago and
so the mclaren has no uh
attraction control or anything it's just
it's massive power to to the wheels so
640 brake horsepower and it only weighs
a ton
so it has massive power weight it can
break wheels free at 80 miles an hour um
so broke the the rear end free and
started spinning
um
and uh i i i sort of uh let's see i
think it was sort of i was going
straight and then turned
um
and and i remember seeing the the the
cars coming towards me while i was going
backwards and then we hit the hit an
embankment um sort of a 45 degree
embankment on sand hill which tossed the
car into the air like a discus and it
kept
kept rotating with about three foot of
air air clearance according to witnesses
um
and then slammed down on on the ground
going the original direction
and we blew the suspension out uh and uh
now it didn't actually wreck the car the
core chassis and the engine were okay
um
but all the glass and the wheels and
everything was shredded and um and there
was massive body damage in the front and
rear
um
and
yeah
did you start laughing
um i don't recall laughing um i i mean
i could have been laughing in shock
but i don't recall laughing um
and um
and then and then peter uh caught a
hitched a ride to to mike i i waited
while the the fire truck and the
ambulance arrived then finally the did
peter thiel literally hitch a ride to to
like to yeah over to to sequoia to yeah
and then then i i once once the car was
uh taken care of then i i used to ride
too
um and so and we
continued the meeting
that's i'm picturing you and peter thiel
like that scene and tommy boy we're like
the deer and you're both like ah
like yeah really
how wow yeah is there apparel
really
i i should say so is there a parallel
with how you build companies in that
story i hope not
let's see what the thing can do
yeah watch this
that could be awkward with a rocket
launch if you want more top 10 videos
they're not on this channel anymore i
have a dedicated channel just for it go
check it out the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and i'll
see you there